doch welche freude mehr single deutsche
und ja ich dann meinen die beschreibung
kommen
willkommen zu einem video ich habe heute
russland dabei kennt ja vielleicht der
ein oder andere so von facebook und
youtube
er ist nicht mehr eine auf jeden fall
wir uns gedacht wir machen ja hast du
jetzt alles und das auf der hand wir uns
gedacht wir machen so ein video das sind
hier ganz nah ist okay jetzt viel
erzählt er ganz viele fragen beziehen
immer abwechslung müssen die beantworten
die sind zum teil etwas niveaulos aber
passt auf jeden fall und lifestyle
schnickschnack ich heute unbedingt sagen
das recht muss anderen ende ein guter
geist weiß was würdest du tun wenn deine
freundin dickere hast als du also kann
man jetzt einmal so verstehen dass sie
halt so die russland in der beziehung
oder das ja wirklich dicke reihe hätte
wie sagt schneider lese die in die
balance und sein diese plätze aber aber
sonst keine ahnung hat solche waffen in
der messe und kälter
das bisschen eklig dass seinem stets
drauf so transportieren
was würdest du tun wenn deine freundin
nicht mit ihrer besten freundin metro
ich würde das wäre eigentlich einig es
wäre auf einer seite scheiße auf meine
stärken liegen wie hat es dir was aus
dem grund stelle kommt nach hause und
dann deine freundin in ihrem essen vor
nackt in einem bett als erstes zu
springen nicht durch das volk ab meinte
auch welche freundin habe dann seine
beschreibung auf jeden fall besser meine
freunde und ich würde mit meiner bis
also mit ihrer besten freundin runden
lenken oder sonst was auch nicht geil
weil sie können sich ja begrüße hallo
sagen dass weder 10 13 jahre lang
was würdest du tun wenn du keine haare
mehr hätte keine ahnung ich denke mal
ich würde mir perücke holen was ist wenn
ich mir klasse sex ich bin ich stell dir
einfach so leute vor mir klasse wie die
wohl aussehen würden oder kennen jetzt
einfach keine haare wie scheiße aussehen
würde aber naja
lange texte alter was würdest du tun
wenn sich beim weißen ring weder dumm
noch der neue normal läuft und du dir
dann noch 40 sekunden hast bist du deine
bauplanung hast weil er nichts mehr
vorbei eigentlich nicht
drei abschicken
ok jetzt kommt die unsere was würdest du
tun wenn deine freundin in der band
ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung
aber ich glaube es wäre dann nicht mehr
meine freunde trifft voll eklig oder
nichtbestehen scheiße was würdest du tun
wenn dein handy im urlaub kaputt amok
laufen da geht mir gar kein ich hoffe
mich abmelde
keine ahnung wie mein handy kaputt ich
glaube wohl ist es nicht allzu tragisch
weil man ist so viel darauf fixiert ist
und vielleicht immer keine cola habe man
kein interesse das wäre echt scheiße
schippmann hatte urlaub nicht einig wer
in deutschland recht
dann würde ich weiß nicht alter habe ich
drauf packen aushändigen keine ahnung
ich finde ich will sterben
nachweislich am rechner kann ihn nicht
so leicht würzig mit stärken wir mit
jeder drei sachen beantwortet wir haben
aber noch einige sachen drin und den
zweiten teil
den gibt es jetzt schön auf jeden fall
kaufen in der beschreibung oder direkt
hier im auto hier nochmal sein
installier mainz und hier im auto
komplett hier zu sein video mit mir auch
und auf der anderen seite zu meinem
letzten video könnt ihr auch noch
irgendwo gestellt
ansonsten wünschen wir euch viel spaß
und noch einen schönen mittwoch und ein
ende